the goal
is to disappear behind our masks as
pleasant
interchangeable helpers it's tropical
kabuki
hello happy to be here we're on our
honeymoon you're such a valued guest
welcome to the white lotus
are they paper nicole they're [ __ ]
huge i haven't seen them in a while
it's cancer swoll balls to say biopsy or
balls dad
not yet surprised
am i interrupting i know it's only your
honeymoon
oh my god look at her face rachel you
were such a beautiful bride
but also very pale but now you have a
little more color and it looks great
thanks you are so talented
do you really know what you're doing
you think you could have dinner with me
at the hotel tonight um
i get off at seven yeah that's good i
mean like a couple minutes after seven
at the
at the restaurant sounds great
being a young man this time right now
can't be easy
why because we can't harass girls
anymore no
well he thinks i'm an [ __ ]
were you an [ __ ] i guess i'm just
wondering what uh you might be able to
do for us to make us feel better
no i was actually trying to not be an
[ __ ]
that you failed
[Music]
where were you i just walked around
[Music]
please enjoy
belinda is the best then i'll make an
appointment if she's not booked with me
sometimes just watching them eat every
night makes me want to
gouge my eyes out belinda
belinda what i want is to speak to your
boss
[ __ ] this place i don't think it's the
most romantic hotel in hawaii do you
it's perfectly fine but are you finding
it very romantic okay
[Music]
you